First, we're affected by what we know.
When I talk to the kids in high school classes, college classes,...
...that's the first thing I tell them.
Get the information while you're here.
Nothing worse than being stupid when you get out of school.
So get the information, being broke is bad, but...
...being stupid is what's really bad.
And what's really really bad is being broke and stupid.
Nothing much worse than that, unless you're sick, right?
Sick, broke, and stupid that's about as far as you can fall unless you're ugly, right?
But surely that would be the ultimate, right?
The ultimate negative life - ugly, sick, broke and stupid.
So learn all you can, we're affected by what we know.
So get the information.
Don't be lazy in learning, don't be lazy in going through the books, building your library,...
...coming to classes like this, consistently, consistently.
Some of them will be so dramatic, your life will never be the same.